well let's let's let's talk about
project veritas yeah so
uh actually i wonder if i have an
article i think
i i did well as you look look for the
article it's important to know a lot of
people got hit
today robert f kennedy jr dell big tree
james o'keefe project veritas there's
other reports of tom mcdonald
having some of his videos taken down
from spotify and apple music i think
they're back up now
but also other individuals like immortal
technique and r.a the rugged man
had their video flagged and be because
it was supposedly election
disinformation their music video wasn't
even about the election
no it's just politics it was just it was
it was a lot of things were about the
cia
but that's a whole other side topic but
they said it was election disinformation
so and then they so and then i've got
i've got important breaking news
yes um project veritas is not
permanently uh banned from twitter good
that's good
so cnn is wrong um as far as i know i
mean
so uh i know james cnn's wrong i know
james o'keefe
and we're uh we've had him on the show
before and i think he's a cool dude i
think it's a good dude i think it is
great work
apparently he's not permanently banned
they suspended his account because they
wanted a certain they
you know you have to remove a certain
tweet the tweet in question
is he confronted a a facebook employee
like any other news organization of
their operations or something yeah yeah
so he was
there they had one of their employees
saying like hey can you answer these
questions and then i was like get out of
here
it was in front of his house now when i
saw that i was like oh but they were at
his house
james quickly in his video points out
bbc does it
fox news does it cnn does it everybody
it is a normal thing
where they go to people's houses and
they ask them questions and they do the
exact same thing
and so he says in this video they will
not be taking it down
because they will not set themselves to
a lower standard than any other news
organization they're going to operate
much the same way as anyone else would
so they appealed it yes apparently
because they appealed the decision
twitter now says the account is
suspended my understanding is it's not
permanent
but cnn claims it is so i wonder if
maybe it really is i mean
i'd have to imagine they say they say
this look
this uh twitter permanently banned an
account on thursday belonging to project
veritas
they say the decision followed what a
twitter spokesperson described as cnn
business as repeated violations of the
platform's policies
prohibiting sharing or threats of
sharing other people's private
information
twitter declined to say what specific
tweets may have been may have triggered
the enforcement action
but in a post on project veritas public
telegram channel thursday afternoon the
group said the suspension occurred after
it published a video
in which project veritas accosted i'm
sir i'm certain project veritas didn't
say they costed anybody
sure facebook vp of integrity is home
they say twitter also confirmed that
o'keefe's personal account had been
locked temporarily
for violating the same policy and that
o'keefe would be required to remove the
violative content before regaining
permission
to tweet in an email statement to cnn
business o'keefe again said it was false
that the video contained private
information and claims twitter told the
group
it could have its account reinstated if
it deleted the tweet containing the
video
so it's interesting that see uh twitter
has refused like declined to say what
what
what
the res what the reason was veritas said
no no it's not permanently banned but
cnn still runs the headline that it is
permanently banned
i guess we'll just have to wait and see
if they come back by the way this is the
same cnn that showed up
at a memers house someone who made memes
at their house was it also them or was
it another organization that threatened
to dox them unless they take down the
means
i mean i mean that's the same news
organization that that's talking about
accosting other individuals i mean you
guys kidding me i mean
the layers of hypocrisy are insane
didn't they go to old lady's house
because she was
sharing russian memes or whatever she
was like a member of a page that the
russians were running
so they like show up at her house and
she's like what what are you talking
about they're like ma'am
you're supporting russian propaganda and
it's like old lady and she's like what
and she goes in her house and like
ignores them um you're crazy so just to
clarify
do i haven't watched enough news to know
but do they go to someone's house
stand outside get a full video shot of
the house yes yeah so it's like
they don't but they blow out the address
nope they show the address
online so that's doxing yep yeah i've
seen that that's illegal right
in sweden they they they hacked the
disc discus a commenting system and then
they doxed anonymous commenters
and showed up to their houses filming is
that illegal
to publish someone's private information
absolutely no because it's technically
public information
yeah um it happens to be accompanied
with like a threat
or something like that but if it's just
that because i've been docked
five six times and it's you can't really
do anything unless it's accompanied with
this is the person's address and people
should go but
but does driver have no doxxing in their
terms of service they're not a lot of
ducks
yeah private information but james
didn't include any private information
i didn't see any address i didn't see
licenses it was actually blurred he
blamed
ours and they were blurred license
plates everything was blurred i mean
it doesn't even matter because the real
point is much like uh gina we were
talking earlier it's just about
anyone who's defiant they're gonna try
to crush you so the fact that they're
not already banned actually amazes me
well this is what's funny
they're going after tucker carlson
because he made comments about george
floyd
and i did a video about this earlier and
i don't look veritas
there was no large uprising where they
were like we must ban james o'keefe
he just got quietly suspended really
really quickly the reason is
james o'keefe is an actual threat to
them because he actually produces video
content
without his opinion in it he might
editorialize he might you know he reads
the the copy and he's the one doing the
voiceover
but when they show you a video of a vp
of facebook saying things
that's not an opinion that's the person
actually saying it might be the vp's
opinion or the employee's opinion
but it's not veritas's opinion tucker
carlson is opinion
is an opinion guy he's an excellent
boogie man for the left
so they can go oh no look at tucker
saying these things everyone quit donate
give me money and
you know subscribe to my my patreon so
we can complain about tucker and then
you know cnn's uh media fox news review
show was like i can't believe tucker
would say that
they don't want tucker band they need
him he's a boogeyman
veritas on the other hand they can't
boogeyman him they try they definitely
do
but they can't show you what he's
actually doing with tucker they show
clips from his show
and they're like look at that opinion
what are you gonna do tucker's a lot
different opinion it could be a dumb pin
you know how to like it
but it's very different yeah they want
to keep tucker around in my opinion
because he's a pressure release valve
for the populist right as is a show like
this in my opinion
not everybody on the bible is right
because we did rag on trump quite a bit
and we do reckon republicans
but it still functions as in essence a
pressure release valve for
those who are freaking out about
censorship tucker is one show on one
channel
up against the entirety of the machine
they demonize him as a boogeyman to keep
people on their side in line
while allowing him to act as a pressure
release valve veritas is an actual
journalistic outlet producing damning
information and exposing the corrupt
nuked yeah the um i think they do fair
unbiased journalism
and for me if it this is like my fox
news or veritas
veritas this is my litmus test for
twitter if they ban
his account for that i'll stop using
twitter completely i have no problem
i've raised my account from like 400
followers to 10
000 in the last six months i've been
heavily using twitter but
what's your twitter ian crossland if
they uh
if they blow this i think i'm going to
mines 100 full-time
yes you know that's the that's the issue
too a lot of us got to put our money
where our mouth is and be more active on
other platforms
that's just that's just it i don't even
care about twitter interactions i don't
even know why i use it
i probably should just start posting on
mines more just that's it i'll do it
yeah i'm building up my email list and i
definitely recommend everyone else
do the same and i'm twitter instagram
i'm just i'm just going to be
extra spicy i have been i've been having
a lot of fun with that if it goes it
goes but i have my email list
we are change the door top right hand
corner means a lot to me i got a better
idea
we talked about we talked about this a
bit on a show last week or so
why don't we just create a can we create
some kind of like federated plug-in for
websites
should so instead of telling people
follow me on twitter i just say
follow me on timcast.com like an rss
we're talking about rebuilding rss so
basically what we could do is we could
create
a feed where i can just pull up an app
on my phone and i can like i would
normally tweet but i would just go to my
own
it would go to timcast.com yeah and we
can all do it so if you go there you'll
see all of us
but then we can also do the same thing
for all of our guests
but then on their websites they do the
same thing and so
basically there is no one social site
it's just essentially rss where
everyone's getting access to this feed
where people are commenting and posting
things
we actually talked about rss3 like going
so we should talk to our incredibly
talented developers that we have in the
house to get some advice
and take that move forward with that
because i think that's a great idea
one of the things that we were talking
about doing is creating a
like a white label software open source
that people can just they can buy a
domain
buy server space and then install the
package and then instantly have a full
social media
site but it's on their server space so
if the hosting company bans them well
that's
you know there you go you can still get
banned but twitter can't do it facebook
can't do it
and then what we do is we just network
them together
in some capacity it would be weaker than
twitter facebook or youtube because the
the networking is is limited compared to
what you can do on twitter like hosting
videos and stuff
but we can still make a rudimentary
system that would work this way
that's that i i think it's probably a
good idea should probably do it i like
that
one of the reasons i started
teamcast.com was because i'm like okay
well i can always post here if i get
banned
so instead of saying f you know follow
me on twitter just
follow me on timcast.com go to the
website we need to make something that
aggregates posts from websites i suppose
so we have like the members only section
maybe we can make a directory that
incorporates
memberships or like content posts from a
ton of different creators
influencers you know com whatever
commentators
that way you have one app where you can
follow everybody but all it is is a
directory
not actually you know a social media
website um
follow their website activity all
through a decentralized
or you can say something well i was just
i don't want to sidetrack uh finish your
points but i
i want to talk about the florida travel
restrictions uh why did you look into it
uh no i was i was hoping maybe we could
pull up a story and then read it
we we will it's that's crazy i guess i
guess we're pretty close to wrapping
this off this one up as it is i guess
the general idea is
is there anybody who wants you know
especially those listening who wants to
put together an
open source very simple white label
package that you can install into a
server that gives you the functionality
of twitter facebook or youtube
and then we can create a parent
directory that just aggregates those so
basically
we make a website called like you know
ian's amazing
you know funhouseadventure.com and when
you go there
if you set up one of these software one
of these white label software programs
on your server
you just put your domain you submit your
domain to the site it gets edited the
directory
and then people can follow and then you
go to this website and you'll see
a list of all the posts from these
websites and then what they could ban
the directory i suppose but the website
still exists
new directories would pop up and you
can't ban it
simple as that you could host video
you'd have to pay to host your own video
that's
kind of a downside but and you have to
pay you'd have to pay to host your own
everything
but hey look if you're going to pay i
mean how much how much it's going to
cost to host text
just text not much right if at all
that'd be like 10 bucks for the domain
and then like you know what 10 bucks a
month or something for server space
right
and then all you're doing is posting
your tweets no one can ban you
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time